i know that you know part of my mission
in life is talking about mental health a
prime
time tv gig give it up for my beautiful
dj
executive producer of her own netflix
series
what are you wearing i'm wearing the
latest skinny jeans
corinne fox is more than just the
daughter of an oscar-winning actor
i've been lucky that my daughter turned
out right
she's becoming a star in her own right
while encouraging fans to prioritize
their mental health
when i was 14 years old going through
this journey
there no there was no self-care movement
there was no one was talking about this
stuff
and i desperately needed somebody who
was talking about it publicly karen was
a young teenager when she was
diagnosed with anxiety disorder i've
been in therapy since i was 14. i've
actually had the same therapist
since i was 14 i'm 27 now so it's 13
years
with this woman who i i absolutely adore
as i get older i have new challenges i
have to learn new coping tools
i'm really curious to know how did
growing up in hollywood
as the jamie foxx's daughter did that
have any effect on your mental health
yeah it's actually something i still
work on i feel like i
developed this intense perfectionism
because
i felt like people were always looking
at me were always
kind of expecting me to you know turn
out a certain way and because of that
i kind of went the opposite realm as as
opposed to being
you know the celebrity kid who goes wild
and crazy i became very
focused on perfection that definitely
affected my mental health and i'm
still working through to unlearn those
behaviors and those patterns and giving
myself the grace to just be a human
in an interview you you mentioned that
your outward confidence at a point in
time
went hand in hand with your self-doubt
in relation to my peers
i've traveled a lot and i do a lot of
different jobs and
i guess from the outside looking in you
might assume oh she's really confident
she does all these you know amazing
things
but what you don't see is all of the
prep work and the med
and the self-talk i have to do to get
myself there
and that i'm panicked half the time and
i'm so nervous especially with new
projects and
i just stepped into a new role as a ep
and
yeah that sounds really cool but i was
terrified the whole time why are you in
your pajamas when we're getting ready to
go to church
i think i'm a pass on church this week
i'm gonna tell you right now everybody
under
this roof goes to church just because
the door opens doesn't mean you
you still have to show up when you walk
in the room let's talk about how you're
proactive
when it comes to your mental health i
have this tool kit that i have created
over the years and i keep it on my phone
for times that i am so anxious
or nervous that i can't even like
remember what do i do when i feel this
way
corinne's guide to wellness how i beat
mental illness every day
so it's really important that i work out
four to five times a week i meditate i
go to therapy
i journal i socialize i'm making sure
i'm getting
seven day hours of sleep when i'm not
feeling well like going to church on
sundays even if it's virtual
um it just you know ups up lifts your
spirits even for a little bit
another thing that keeps karen on track
is telling her story
which has been amplified since
partnering with the national alliance on
mental health
i think talking about your mental health
is
not a weakness it's a sign of strength
because so many people are afraid to do
it and if
you step out and you're saying i need to
have a personal day or i need help or
i'd love to talk about this
that shows that you're emotionally aware
enough
to to ask for that help and that's a
sign
of strength
[Music]